今日はたまに頻発にして頻発が似合うと言われています始め雪はです2で今回なんです
けどもう
現代のホスト界の帝王と呼ばれているローランドさんに来ていただいておりますどうぞ
よろしくお願いあーございますロスなんだろうランダーデー
痛いですよねどうせ同じく年弱ね食べもいいですか
全然分いいという
石行くんだろブーブー
ないしなんか御在所岳打つか意味ないからねそうねっ
全然今日はブランドだって待ってくれ林田からは白せ
なぜ来られて嬉しいなと思って
じゃあいらっしゃいません
だけで今日経ぞあ大丈夫大丈夫だよね
岩盤与えるへの道小規模使ったねーよいいいいいい you do イザー
の大金どうなんだろカプセルアーサー in loro 西9レイプっレンズワーッ
ってちょっと増やしていこう
から牛すごいてる一番200720年と先発は1杯当たり方が高
受け10分けてくれる
正しい会議どうなるん最近俺はねぇ
最近ちょっと当店引越していて自分からあればでそれもちょっと来たんだ
アップを請け負い出てくるみたいな話を
親を呼ぶ目標に家ができたから生活に慣れる
4時間はカーソーラー東京もねございます
ていたら是非これ全部
いやを大都市なのにこんなさあ出るって言うよいいえ
カッパーいいんですよローランドさん本文ロランかっこいいよ
学校やてぃ難易度シニョンこんなにふっくらちゃ
これなんだろ佐竹
ブーブー髪色それはあの家のブーブー言いあの言い方の提供して1泊4泊チャーキティ
レベルじゃんジャズ曲は値上げして頂け来ていい掛けるんだけどその時に一緒に買った
でしたいっ
うん髪色にしたいという人向けに全く同じ俺がやってる施術を破くパップがあって
すげー
じゃあそれをやればこれもローラーとゴールドに金ですけど方
まあそうだねっ
早く男に速い今日で3ヶ月輝く男になるために
ローランドゴールドの髪色になってローランドさんに近づこうと思いますよろしくお
願いしまーすその結果に支部
何がいい
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
[音楽]
me
では早速ぐ
よろしくお願いますよろしくとりあえず者スタッフの紹介をね寝させてくれをお願いし
ますそれので6年くらいも担当してくれてて
ながーい
ブーブー s 僧侶古いとかされたことあります
ありますねそのときどうですか必死みたりとか
めちゃくちゃ痛かったですあああればの the world 知ってるこれこれよ
ねー
流れねうりつ式水
使って
ブーブー言いしかーし
me
絶対サングラス取った方がいいですよねを外しあおいあおい
そこだけくっ黒くなってるからあっチップスてメってか小池
とこだけ俺も結構であの
はじめしゃちょー立していることが保有すきてをぜひぜひ
なんか逆にであったりする導通ホストだか未知の業界なんで
ああ
やっぱローラーのさお酒強いんですか
派遣で下げていく強いよなぁただなんか
これ車で借金住んで好きであ7んだロードでその技とかむしろ誰か桜ロールつですね
車を運転している=がまずに売り上げ上げられてる証拠じゃ確かに充填なっちゃうから
そうだからのますそしてお前
かっこいいそう強い riccia 余韻すればよいいなーっ
次の日ももうドラ日にシビックタイプだよなぁ
遠くでいます
俺が来てだったのはユーチューバーがまあポピュラーじゃないんだからさ
参入したじゃんらその全県ためとはそこまあなんか
ポピュラーじゃない公開やっていこうみたいなぁ
なんで後発でいようと思ったのかネットなんか人気になろうという
あー有名になりたかったそうですが僕も教育学部だったんですよなぁ
学校の先生を志すっていうた手前象をちょっと
は言えなかったちょっと恥ずかしかったんだなぁ
結構たとえ話の好きだってくださ
あの人施工ブスって言って海の向こうがもうなんか断崖絶壁で指の僕をいけないみたい
なそういう説が
の貰いうまッ諸説あるがあるとなってるコロンブスの一人は地球てた悪いから北まで
トチロー底から運行
ピクドアって
いったわけよん
でそっから頃娘実際に切って地球が回るだったけど証明されてその後にさ行くのって
簡単じゃ
落ちるか落ちないのもわかってるから落ちないってことが道があります今そうそうで
一番最初にやっぱ行った奴がさ一番お礼ライト
うーんその出てきたらそういう
開拓しては youtube で食ってけるだって誰も思わなかった時代にさ
そうですよね猫はすごいよすっ僕らを振ってんだい
このないです委員会な動物くれている今が楽しいんで
ああ
これを続けるのは読めるんですああ
二回裏の山は目標とか言えば
俺はねなんかだからもし分京都が湧別ができたらもうその明日にでも居る
行動しているタイプだうーん今はない
でももし教会へついてきたらあしたいですと夢に向かって
うーんマンションコツ
だから枠目に同じ幹事会で踊ってあったらとりあえず何が農家のへ譲渡をちゃいます
塗ってるんですがもう実在を見てます結構色かーっ
ほんと本ドラマー新たりはしてない今のところすちょちょっとこれで毛先塗り終わって
から少し変わってその後ね持っているので
その時新田れてくださいローランドその言いたくなかったり
ん俺はでもなぁ誰だよねー
なあ
痛いって彼から聞いてもがないからですすげー書く気はの歌来ないよねああああ
これで1回あっためていきます実はところを走らせ
はい
me 2
ん
はい時でドーラとさんは帰ってしまいますね
いくらやっていこうと思いますよぜよろしくお願いしますちょっとここから根元を塗っ
ていきますの実はこっから言いたい可能性が
はい頑張ってございます
きてます全然わからないー
[音楽]
ぐらいかな
13ん
でメンツの下のほうがいいと
こういうタイプの人が多いんだよね紙製でいてくらい日本で日目ぐらい
ここにも一人母まじですかはい
ん出すために全然ないね
[音楽]
もう
ああああああああ
大丈夫ですよ先生に対するはこうじゃないですよ
[音楽]
ローラさん所ですかうぇい
5年にもありました這い上がれ号からもうちょっと置いて入るも終了ですので
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
廃墟で20分くらい放置しましたどうですかねぇ
すっきり明るくなっていることが分かります
パニチってくるん
くま日記ぱに供与された
[音楽]
ブーバーしぞ
じゃあ洗い流せていただきますん
ありがとうござい変わりますは
ずに取らず7えっ
だがジムニー区のダメージリペアを使って
ビターが出てまいりましたかなとか e とかあったら言ってねはずだって言って
言える奴泣かなきゃいけない
[音楽]
もう普通に上手ですねとシャンプー次第は俺28年かやってるからね
浅田3匹はないんですねいいキャラがユーザープレイ記は
までもこれ凄いわなか泡立ちは
いいの言語はものですね
the 轍強いほうがさ洗っているかあるからさんの事例ションってゲームなくすごい
サップ楽しいよ挙げてこない
前編があってクエもれたりでもついに母
しっ
うぼうぜい
ぜってそれで言える人生動画で b
いいよいいんじゃないでしょうかありがとうございます食べねーとかある
たりへのがないです本当の良い気がしないっていいです
1 be a fine
ok
[音楽]
はいえーいました
デラックスというふうにダメージピックやトリートメントはねやっていきたいと思うん
ですけどさっきは同じ良かったんでこれはどういう仕上がりになるという
使って言ったり言われだいぶ
ブリーチした後だからダメージがん
出席されているんで
ケアしていきますね
めっちゃいいにする
何の匂いだこれねなあフルーティーですよ
by ん
nerv
普通は船ざいましたっけめっちゃ温まった金で
電極しっとりしてるんん
指で俺もいいし
全然いいよねこれいいです
[音楽]
んな感じから
ありがとうございますじゃあこれを
また流してもらおうはいお願いします
[音楽]
長川だしている時も香りがめちゃくせにですねー
t you do
んじゃそういうスラリーの女の子の後ろ髪からこういうさあいるからだ
入学生に良いです
me
ぶーランドゴールドはじめ雪をパーランド
完成です
入っていうねローランのゴルゴ部屋は彼らに会ったということで実際のうおおおお
ランドさんを読んで感想聞いてみたいと思います
あげ
あおいーじゃんどうですかちょっと違ったんだよねもうちょっとれちゃうわー
パンに1比べたらやっぱ違うよね俺でもあるコーヒー
強いからああいう時間を経てもやれるのに敵だと結構怒って入ってきた本日買った
こちらのシャンプーラックスノーレミー来た明治リピアシリーズはですね
売上ナンバーワングランドトラックスからを愛している
4 c 言語シャンプーですロンシリコーンシャンプー
んですけれども木島濡れて髪の補修分艶を貸してくれるという
すげーさんとでございます匂いと思う2分掴みよい入浴をする
詳しい情報を動画の概要欄からチェックできますのでぜひ見てみてくださいそして
ローランドさんとコラボ動画ですね
プロなんじゃねえええ
ブーバーンにゃんだよ
el reloj